the e uh the u.s and the eu have
announced a plan to reduce european
countries dependence on russian gas at a
joint news conference with eu commission
chief usler fonder lion president joe
biden promised the u.s would deliver
more liquefied natural gas to europe
this year he also said the current
crisis is an opportunity to boost
renewable energy sources
let's hear what joe biden had to say
earlier
we're coming together to reduce europe's
dependence on russian energy
putin has issued russia's energy
resources to coerce
and manipulate its neighbors that's how
he's used it he's used the profits to
drive his war machine
this initiative focuses on two core
issues one
helping europe reduces dependency on
russian gas as quickly as possible
secondly
reducing europe's demand for gas overall
we're going to cross now to brussels
where all of this has been happening and
we can speak to our bureau chief there
alexandra von neumann alexandra tell us
how significant is this deal between the
eu and the u.s
well the deal is definitely very
significant we are not talking here
about delivering additional volumes of
liquified natural gas to europe both
sides the us and europe are again
presenting and unite a united front and
they are deepening their energy
partnership and promising to produce and
use more renewable energies in the
future to reduce greenhouse gases and
this is definitely a win-win situation
for both sides
so a new energy partnership but will the
lng from the us be be enough to replace
uh russian gas supplies
no it won't
and that's of course something that we
have to stress as well the us has
promised to deliver at least 15 billion
cubic meters of liquefied natural gas to
europe this year and it's just 10 of
what russia is delivering every year in
2021
the european union received 155
billion cubic meter meters
and you can understand that this is a
long way to go to reduce
those deliveries or the dependence on
natural gas from russia however we have
to say that anything that could help the
european union reduce its dependence and
stabilize the markets is welcome here
now we know that eastern member states
such as poland had been pushing for a
complete boycott of russian gas yet
germany has blocked this move can you
tell us more about that
well germany is not the only country the
only member state blocking a total gas
embargo because it's also austria for
example but germany is of course an
economic powerhouse in europe and
the chancellor told us yesterday that
it's just too early to decide on that
because germany is still very dependent
on russian deliveries and that it's
important to diversify energy deliveries
but that is going to take time and that
is why germany is saying
and total
natural gas embargo it's not on the
table right now
dw brussels bureau chief alexander von
naaman thanks so much
the u.s has agreed to rapidly boost
shipments of liquefied natural gas or
lng to europe this year as part of
efforts to wean the continent off
russian fuel the announcement came
during president joe biden's visit to
brussels for a host of meetings on
russia
the americans will offer an additional
15 billion cubic meters of lng by year's
end
last year they shipped 22 billion cubic
meters to europe the eu hopes to replace
two-thirds of russian gas imports by
year's end
now germany is also racing to reduce its
reliance on russian fossil fuels the
government reporting today it's made
progress over the last month the economy
minister now says the country will be
able to have its oil imports from russia
by summer it expects to end to coal end
its coal purchases altogether by the
fall and by year's end it will import
only 30 of its gas from russia compared
to 55 percent before the war
now germany is going to need more
natural gas not just from the us but
also from suppliers in the gulf regions
such as qatar it's a country with
enormous gas
reserves but a controversial record on
human rights
qatar is a top producer of liquefied
natural gas or lng seen as critical for
germany weaning itself off russian
imports
but the gulf country is also well known
for its stained human rights record
rights groups criticized the
exploitation of qatar's 2 million
migrant workers
the deaths of thousands of workers over
the past decade have gone ignored by
authorities modest labor reforms have
reportedly stalled
other reports point to restricted
freedom of expression and the repression
of women
as germany frantically searches for new
trade partners should the country put
human rights at the forefront of its
trade relations
against the background of german history
it's a very important topic
everybody should think about this when
buying products our constitution says
human dignity is invaluable
that also cancer other countries from
which we purchase products
definitely i think especially with
globalization which is increasing we
can't avoid the topic
yeah i think it's important but it's
difficult
we can see that with habeck's visit to
the uae and the gulf states
it's like choosing between the lesser of
two evils
for berlin finding reliable energy from
reliable partners is now a problem with
no easy solution
so far pragmatism prevails